los dulces de frutos secos y miel tienen
raíces en el Antiguo Egipto milenios
después los árabes difundieron en sus
conquistas esas recetas vinculadas a sus
celebraciones religiosas y así ocurrió
en otros lugares del mundo donde el
turrón forma parte de la Navidad Navidad
anntar es experto en confeccionarlas
de cacahuate el lugar el de almendras o
el de avellanas Hacemos todos son los
dulces del cumpleaños del profeta es la
tercera generación de pasteleros y con
49 años tiene más de 30 de práctica por
intuición conoce los tiempos y las
texturas que debe lograr
la textura debe ser como si fuera
cristal
la historia de navila es inseparable de
la de naderatía y de la de la confitería
El Nilo que fundó el abuelo de nadería
hace 100 años
la tienda se abrió en 1928 al principio
era conocida como la pastelería del rey
porque el rey fuat el padre del Rey
faruk solía comer los dulces de aquí
entre sus favoritos estaba el turrón de
almendra ungirlache como el que siglos
antes se consumía en al-ándalus y que se
elabora con miel glucosa y almendras los
árabes lo habían llevado a las costas
del Mediterráneo donde se ha hecho un
hueco hasta nuestros días en la
confitería del nido se elabora con la
misma receta desde hace un siglo y desde
que el abuelo de nader fundó la
confitería ha habido en el Obrador un
miembro de la familia de Navidad
otras tiendas compran parte de los
ingredientes porque no tienen un chef
que sepa cómo hacerlos yo lo tengo el
aprendió de su padre y el padre aprendió
del suyo
cuando veo el producto final me siento
orgulloso si no estoy convencido de ello
creo que a nadie le gustará me tiene que
gustar primero a mí
la calidad de los productos
seleccionados sumados a la experiencia y
devoción al trabajo herencia de
generaciones de Navidad y nader son la
clave para obtener un resultado a la
altura de Reyes